ne mentez pas je sais que vous voulez en
voir plus sur les sites web du futur du
tout ce qu'ils ont tous deux seront
retrouve sur chrome experiments parce
qu'on veut voir plus de sites web du
futur nador et le futur où commence avec
sa rivale selon oil âge parce que whaou
ont pas ça vaut pas trop faire quoi
d'autre oh mon dieu mon dieu ça c'est le
futur ça oh mon dieu regardez avec les
images à droite c'est incroyable je suis
un escroc j'avoue c'est chiant je vais
pas vous mentir illustre ait au c'est
juste l'ubs en attente
il ya des trucs à faire la horde mon
dieu attend ces styles et là l'un des
intrus colleter avec ça me fait des
cernes de malades et attend si je fais
ça ça marche
mais oui on voit on voit mon set up ans
et celle plus tard on m'a juste ma barbe
qui est extrêmement dégueulasse c'est
génial j'ai adoré ce site 10 sur 10
alors toi dans l'appui à ces obus que
j'habite paris juge je sors d'europe
sera plus est ce que c'est beau
ok on voit on voit ma forme dans la
pluie mais c'est génial à les suivre au
kef est difforme heures balaj plateforme
est encore excellent à ok sa traque ma
tête c'est l'exemple que ma tête à
tajine d'être mal le bug mais exit
romane serda matin soixante police c'est
à quel ambassadeur du futur ça sellal
les photos nos la lame et ses coûts
c'est quoi ça c'est quoi ce bug
huawei donc là tu as une petite école de
commerce après je suis allé au bureau
la colère ça vous agace et la colère ou
le choléra
on s'est pas ouverte youtube ainsi que
celle inverse du tube oh la tête à
claques
j'ai adoré voilà ceux des bureaux de
cette vidéo allez hue mme azila ya aussi
bien ça va se transforment en animaux
c'est bien ce soir je suis un cheval
c'est ça ça s'arrache trop mal
gigamon aux côtés et au mais [ __ ] je
prends une photo voilà voilà le futur en
ou photos j'adore le futur pas mon dieu
qu'est ce que c'est que ça saleilles
attends mais si en fait ceci je pensais
qu'on allait pouvoir faire ça et on se
retrouve à faire ça
ne le persil downtime europe c'est quoi
ça ça va nous faire rire en est jeté
porte attention mouche super vite à bon
dieu voyage vous téléporte ça va ou quoi
what a pas eu le temps de voir mon gars
c'est génial c'est génial et pendant
celle ci de la vidéo non mais on va pas
se mentir ce bloc boîte d'accord on en
est là bas je passe un super moment
franchement aux attendes là on va
s'amuser pendant une heure c'est trop
bien ça c'est moins d'une seconde salle
à illéla regard des moyennes secondes il
est la moyenne je vous arrête de me
c'est génial assez manichéen tête
d'accord ça met du temps quand je parle
c'est super mec au le stress ultime à
booster c'est quoi tes os mais qu'il
était beau savoir wang et pendant une
seconde
regarde en fait ça fait des petits
replay puis des ralentis c'est
exceptionnel colorz ouais je mets tous
les filtres il s'aggrave d'un coup photo
de profil swag voix lacoste
merci à tous merci à tous m'a fait
plaisir c'est génial josh de réflecteurs
qu'est ce que c'est à dire votre
smartphone accéder à l'adresse du
navigateur en attend c'est le futur là
et donc c'est ce à quoi un mec sait où
en fait c'est la lampe torche génial
c'est quoi déjà travaux car des
mongoliens tous ces supports badens
j'arrête ode à tous paiements dans le
studio amodio thème c'est quoi ça c'est
juste en fait et progression
d'extraterrestres mon gars c'est un
google traduction pour les aliens
horrible horrible cas c'est terrible
c'est quoi ça a un prix que free style
même si chez par ap crochet par apg
arrive et tout le monde se met à pied je
vous paie un regret que vous oubliez
tout de suite elles vont observer mais
non c'est quoi ce délire mon gars tu en
feras tu es l'aider avec les yeux c'est
parfait c'est vraiment tout ce qu'on
aime c'est des tests et yeux gm faisait
pas dire badens et les yeux the aude
kooples ou sam x de visage c'est ça on
va prendre une photo de nous voilà et
1,2 au oui d'accord ça me mixa avait
glissé goûter c'est fantastique on va
mixer avec pharrell williams d'accord on
en est là on dirait juste un [ __ ]
oiseaux à grand bec et en plus ils font
bouger le visage pour pas que tu vois
que c'est un peu mal faite technique
d'escrocs galets ça dégage ce culte au
remuant pour sculpter
ah oui tiens là on va tellement
révolutionner la assez sympa une fois
j'ai fait un tour à jouer et quand
j'étais petit est en fait le tatouage il
a fait ça sur ma peau jamais le tatouage
met en relief avec des boutons voilà
washington de merde mais s'appuieront
pour ça c'est pour ça ça m'évoque rien
d'autre ça c'est de l'art vous savez
j'ai eu vent de cette boule un musée
incroyable aux champignons ou vont voter
le porter ou pas d'insultés raconte
auster samek ce parti révolution ou
trois deux un incroyable
c'est incroyable et elle le futur voilà
thurella génial google plutôt intégrer
l'interface google mais qui part en
steaks tess ça marche
non ça marche pas d'accord tu peux tout
déplacer pts à 6 et où on vient de
casser google monga baie des cochons
sauvages à l'épaule n'est pas un petit
avec de la musique majoritaire de la
musique au
voilà on va composer un repas composé va
composer
où
trop dur merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo
c'est l'heure nous y aille je sais pas
ap voilà genre c'est-à-dire
pédagogiquement la caméra je fais une
duel de mecs gêné au revoir voilà tout
est dit à la baisse et voilà j'espère
quand il n'était pas là les soeurs vous
a plu à l'est rapidité je pense que nous
en avons fait le tour de tous les sites
du futur mais vu que c'est râpé retour
ici depuis trois ans par les sites qui
étaient du futur il ya trois ans
maintenant c'est ici du présent donc
c'est plus si le futur vous avez compris
à 13 reprises et là ça ne me regarde et
portez vous bien que tout le monde
puisse